jean luc bideau bonjour jour vous êtes
le directeur de la maison de
l'entreprise depuis sa création en 2000
à saint quentin en yvelines et puis là
on est au théâtre on venait souvent au
théâtre
oui ça m'arrive maintenant je suis saint
quentinois donc voyez quelques années
donc je fréquente occasionnellement
théâtre alors on se dit toujours à ce
que les jeunes entreprises fréquentent
la culture ben oui oui je crois que oui
et puis il ya des efforts entre
guillemets de part et d'autre tant du
point de vue du théâtre que des
entreprises pour des rapprochements de
plus en plus régulier j'espère efficace
alors vous êtes directeur de cette
maison de l'entreprise depuis sa
création
oui le puits fin 99.99 donc ça fait
bientôt de 13 ans mais dans la ferme
pourquoi une maison d'autres prisons se
dire à quoi ça sert pas les autres
prises il y en a beaucoup
sur ce territoire sont pas assez grandes
pour venir tout alors c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on compte 7000
entreprises qui est intéressant pour un
territoire comme celui de saint quentin
mais ce qu'il faut peut-être rappeler
c'est le contexte dans lequel tout ça
c'est fait c'est vrai que saint quentin
en yvelines est une ancienne ville
nouvelle donc avec toutes les
particularités de la construction assez
rapide d'une ville nouvelle et toutes
les bases de cette agglomération se sont
faites principalement à l'origine autour
des grands groupes
donc là d'un certain nombre d'années la
réflexion était menée
autour des pme notamment savoir comment
on pourrait favoriser la création et le
développement des pme tout en synergie
autour de ces grands groupes d'où la
création d'une structure comme la maison
d'entreprise voilà sachant que l'idée
aussi de départ c'était de ne pas se
substituer les compétences existantes de
ne pas faire le boulot à la place des
autres mais au contraire de fédérer de
mobiliser toutes ses forces vives qui
gravitent autour du développement
économique pour les mettre en valeur en
complémentarité et permettre ainsi aux
entreprises de se développer dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
oui alors parce que la maison de
l'entreprise donc c'est ce que vous
devez savoir évidemment à toutes les
entreprises mais plus particulièrement
aux petites et moyennes entreprises un
sens c'est eux qui ont besoin de votre
aide de votre expérience de votre
expertise aussi voilà sur la partie
accompagnement principalement voilà on a
aujourd'hui des des compétences qui
s'adresse principalement aux tpe et pme
donc aux petites et moyennes entreprises
après on a développé au fil des années
un certain nombre de services
complémentaires avec la des synergies
avec les grands groupes qui structurent
notamment le territoire combien il ya
j'ai lu le nombre d'entreprises crise
qui s'installe chaque année c'est
absolument phénoménale c'est toujours un
peu délicat de parler de création
d'entreprise sur deux près de 200
dragonair on n'a plus que ça je pense
que ça on recense pas loin de 400 à 500
créations d'entreprises regard sur un
territoire comme le nôtre
sachant que la tour 9 heures c'est
récurrent si donc les entreprises se
créent et se développe se transforme et
meurent pour certaines d'entre elles
d'où effectivement ce mouvement
perpétuel
et quand on dit 400 entreprises
évidemment il ya des deux dans des
entreprises unipersonnelles enfin selon
emploi qu'une personne ou alors qu'ils
emploient 2 maximum tout à fait on est
vraiment dans l'état une entreprise
totalement différente alors qu'elle est
laide
ça s'adresse beaucoup à ces nouveaux
entrepreneurs si enfin aux jeunes
entrepreneurs ou des gens qui veulent
s'installer qu'elle est laide que vous
rapportez pour lors du conseil
principalement
on est sur un bassin d'activités comme
partout d'ailleurs ceci étant ou des
porteurs de projets peuvent être très
avancés dans leurs idées mais d'autres
en revanche
viennent nous voir sans trop d'idée
préconçue donc on essaie de s'adapter
aux différents stades de la réflexion
différents stades de des projets pour
leur apporter les connaissances et les
compétences tant sur le plan juridique
comptable que fiscal voilà avec des
dispositifs de financement que nous
avons mis en place depuis quelques
années maintenant pour proposer un
package dois dire complet qu'on espère
complet pour les entreprises de notre
territoire
oui ça d'attractivité enfin vous êtes ne
les représente de l'attractivité du
territoire vis-à-vis des entreprises
voilà c'est ça on essaie d'être une
porte d'entrée une sorte de guichet
unique pour ces entreprises qui veulent
s'installer
sachant qu'on a la chance pour saint
quentin en yvelines d'être sûr à tout un
territoire comme bull izik est
particulièrement attractif donc les
personnes et les entreprises qui
viennent frapper à notre porte sont sont
nombreuses au quotidien et vous propose
même des études de marché oui bien sûr
c'est le préalable à toute création
d'entreprise
c'est vrai que pour s'installer il faut
savoir si le marché existe si un
potentiel de développement
donc on met à disposition de ces
personnes des outils et on les
on lisait dans le développement de ces
études de marché si vous êtes arrivée
qui des entrepreneurs offert des futurs
entrepreneurs qui viennent nous voit et
que leur phase i et changer un peu
d'avis c'est compliqué parce qu'on n'est
pas dans une science exacte
la création à la vie de l'entreprise et
soumises a énormément d'aléas que
personne ne maîtrise finalement en
dehors du chef d'entreprise lui même
donc difficile pour nous de dire de
manière un peu radicale à quelqu'un qui
est unique a une idée pour qu'un projet
relativement bien ficelé en tête que son
projet ne sera pas viable parce que
d'abord on ne maîtrise pas nous toutes
les gorges toutes les cordes et toutes
les données pour être certain des
informations qu'on va lui donner
donc on essaie de mettre en place un
certain nombre d'indicateurs de tirer
quelques signaux d alarme
mais in fine et la décision revient aux
créateurs d'entreprise alors avant un
petit sujet qui montrera comment ce
passe et un contact entre quelqu'un qui
vient chercher des conseils et la maison
de l'entreprise
je venais pendant un mois ici dans ses
locaux où j'ai eu une formation de
gestion et de comptabilité bon c'était
un nouveau domaine pour moi donc ça a
permis un peu de prendre conscience de
tout ce qui était trésorerie comment
planifier tout ça et puis ensuite il ya
le business plan et le business plan
syrie la maison d'entreprise m'a
accompagné dans ce business plan pour
quand vous êtes scientifique on vous dit
fait un business plan à trois ans
c'est un peu difficile donc c'est vrai
que là on a été j'étais accompagné on
m'a expliqué comment on pouvait décliner
toutes les charges toutes les dépenses
futures et quel est le besoin que
j'aurai pour pour réaliser pour démarrer
ce qui était rassurant c'est que les
autour de moi donc que ce soit la maison
de l'entreprise ou propofol quand
j'avais des questions des inquiétudes
sur des points précis de gestion ou de
trésorerie ou autre il y avait quelqu'un
qui est expert du domaine qui
m'expliquait avec des termes simples ce
que c'était et comment comment anticiper
cette problématique sans la maison
d'entreprise je l'aurais fait quand même
puis c'était déjà un choix familial à
vendre quand on décide de création
d'entreprise ce
on se concerte en famille et il ya
beaucoup de sacrifices qui vont êtres
qui sont mis en place notamment on paye
de sa personne en terme de temps il faut
travailler plus pour démarrer est ce que
j'aurai réussi peut-être s'arrêter un
peu plus difficile jean luc berho auprès
de 12 13 ans maintenant de présence à la
tête de la maison de l'entreprise
est ce que il est comme ça il ya
quelques actions 12 est fier de vous
souvenez où on a aidé un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui aujourd'hui sont
devenus grands certains mêmes d'entre
elles mêmes sont son côté aujourd'hui en
bourrique donc quand les relativement
fier effectivement lorsqu'on a contribué
en toute modestie à la création
développement de ces entreprises
maintenant c'est vrai qu'on a développé
également en complément de cet
accompagnement à la création
d'entreprise on a développé un certain
nombre d'actions notamment au niveau des
animations économique
tous les deux ans on essaie de faire
venir sur le territoire une personnalité
du monde économique donc récemment nous
avons la présence de louis schweitzer
mais j'ai en mémoire également la
présence lors d'une de nos journées du
de l'inventeur de la carte à puce donc
c'est un nombre d'efforts également le
reno en termes de réflexion pour le
problème territoire réussir et donc
voilà donc c'était on a effectivement
quelques souvenirs très très fort sur
notre territoire et puis la fierté aussi
d'avoir mis récemment en place un outil
de financement qui est très demandé par
les entreprises
donc quand je dis la fierté elle est
collective cette fierté parce que comme
l'ensemble des actions que nous menons
soin de se situe dans un contexte très
partenariale et avec des organismes qui
a priori n'était pas forcément destiné à
très bien travaillé ensemble au départ
on a réussi à mettre en place un outil
qui pour chacun d'entre nous paraît
aujourd'hui très performant et utiles
aux entreprises
alors on va parler un petit peu de vous
enfin que d'essence vous êtes un
doubiste est originaire du doubs de
pontarlier exactement mais je suis
je suis né dans cette région qui a la
particularité d'être particulièrement
froides en 3d absolument puisqu'on
atteindre parfois des températures qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à moins 30 au moins
donc effectivement j'ai passé une
vingtaine d'années dans cette région du
doubs avant de quitter la franche comté
pour pour paris paris v coupe poursuivre
mes études
non il ya un personnage qui n est très
connu un homme politique éminent qui
était maire de punta liste et c'est
edgar faure absolument vous avez connu
enfin alors j'étais tirer relativement
jeune à l'époque mais effectivement il a
été maire de pontarlier quelques années
et on se souvient de la fameuse phrase
qui qu'il a souvent cité en disant que
ce n'était pas le vent qui tourne mais
là vous avez votre droit a bola sens et
ça voilà donc j'ai fait des études de
droit et puis j'ai terminé par un dess
d'économie c'est le reste il faut
absolument voilà tout à fait donc j'ai
baigné assez rapidement dans le domaine
de l'économie et dans le domaine de
l'entreprise avec des avec des fonctions
de des stocks de commerce voilà tout à
fait donc avant d'arriver ici j'ai
j'ai travaillé dans différents
organismes dans des chambres consulaires
des chambres de commerce dans un premier
temps dans la nièvre à nevers pendant
quelques années
et puis j'ai travaillé presque cinq ans
à la chambre de commerce de versailles à
proximité de saint quentin donc pour
finir pour terminer en tout cas depuis
quelques années ici à saint quentin en
yvelines dans le cadre de la communauté
d'agglomération 10 à votre fonction
c'est la microéconomie un cd comme une
autre mais vous êtes aussi un passionné
de macroéconomie là c'est vrai que j'ai
cette passion qui plus tôt l'économie au
sens large du terme enfin une vue plus
tôt macroéconomique et et c'est vrai que
ça me permet à la fois peut-être deux
séries de travers la microéconomie que
l'on exerce au travers de nos métiers
ici mais oui effectivement j'ai cette
passion qui menait bien avant mes études
et dans le contexte actuel mais
effectivement ça permet aussi de
comprendre et d'analyser les choses et
vous sentez la demande justement des
entreprises par rapport aux financements
par rapport au financement par rapport
aux besoins qui dès qu'il pourrait être
lui le financement est un besoin
perpétuel mais on est aujourd'hui dans
un
un paradoxe c'est à dire que les
entreprises ont besoin d'argent et les
banques
quelque part peuvent regretter de ne pas
avoir suffisamment de demandes donc on a
à la fois c'est de ces deux versions en
fonction du côté avec les dans lequel on
se se positionne et c'est effectivement
relativement complexe juste un petit mot
encore sur vous on est dans un théâtre
vous avez fait 10ans conservatoire de
musique voilà tout à fait où j'ai fait
de la trompette pendant pendant un
certains nombre des très
occasionnellement mais enfin j'ai des
enfants qui ont pris le relais en terme
de musique et qui joue du piano et c'est
vrai qu'on a oui donc c'est significatif
et si c'est absolument ya un côté
sportif puisqu'elle vous êtes un
marathonien
enfin j'ai fait le marathon de paris
2009 c'est une belle expérience
effectivement une ambiance absolument
extraordinaire là tout à fait c'est un
challenge personnel un petit peu fou
d'ailleurs au départ puisque je n'ai pas
le cas pas forcément la condition les
conditions requises et vidéo un mois
vous enfin oublier un moment pour le
préparer d'abord il faut réformer
transmettre en tout cas c'était une
belle expérience à ce que les agences de
vie et on nous ressort assez fier
absolument vous êtes quelqu'un comme ça
qu'ils se lancent des défis
oui assez assez régulièrement je pense
que ça a aidé effectivement c'est un
petit peu dans le sens des décisions que
l'on doit prendre aussi des fois d'un
point de vue professionnel donc et tout
ça permet de se remettre en cause
parfois elles marathon en l'occurrence
est une véritable épreuve
une preuve de vie parce que 42 km
effectivement on passe par différentes
étapes et ont pesé mais laisse un
parcours de vie de manière assez
intéressant merci infiniment jean-luc
yahoo